Marilyn la dernière vérité documentaire
signée par François Pomès Marilyn Monroe
qui n'a jamais connu son père une
souffrance parmi d'autres que la rue du
mal à surmonter mais 60 ans après sa
mort et grâce à la génétique cette
énigme on vient de le voir vient d'être
élucidé car Marilyn Monroe continue
d'intriguer de passionnés qui étaient
finalement l'une des stars du cinéma les
plus aimées mais aussi l'une des plus
seules Hollywood et jamais engendré nous
allons en débattre maintenant avec nos
invités présents sur ce plateau de débat
doc avec vous pour commencer Sébastien
cochon bienvenue vous êtes auteur
cinéphile et collectionneurs
spécialistes de Marilyn Monroe vous avez
signé des entretiens avec les plus
grands photographes qui ont eu
l'occasion de photogrer photographier la
star et ce dans de nombreux magazines et
vous êtes l'auteur de Marilyn
1962 un ouvrage publié chez Stock
Guillemette audicino est également avec
nous bienvenue vous êtes journaliste
chef de la Rub cinéma à l'hebdomadaire
Télérama vous êtes également
chroniqueuse sur France Inter et c'est
dans l'émission grand bien vous fasse
Sébastien cochon vous nous avez ramené
une petite pépite des États-Unis pour
compléter le film que nous venons de
voir à l'instant il s'agit d'une carte
qu'a envoyé stanleyford autrement dit le
père biologique de marine Monroe on le
sait maintenant après avoir vu ce
documentaire et cette carte regardez là
voilà la traduction en cher Maryline une
carte joyeuse et réconfortante pour te
transmettre tout particulièrement mais
pensez mes meilleurs vœux ainsi qu'une
prière rajoute-t-il à la main ils sont
avec toi tous les jours cette carte donc
a été trouvée aux États-Unis tout
récemment étant approuvé qu'il y avait
bien une correspondance entre son père
mais oui et c'est ça qui est marine qui
est fou avec Marilyn c'est que 60 ans
après on fait encore des découvertes
avec des documents comme ça qui
ressurgissent et cette carte elle vient
à la fois conforter ce que les
documentaire sur le fait que Guy Ford
était bien son père parce que maintenant
on en a la preuve via les examens qui
ont été faits et en même temps un peu le
fermentir parce que on nous dit qu'elle
ne l'a jamais connu que c'était son sa
grande souffrance en réalité il semble
que si il y a eu un contact il y a eu
des échanges il y avait déjà en 94 quand
même la demi-sœur de Marilyn Bernis
miragol avec écrit un ouvrage assez
personnel qui a vu un certain succès où
elle racontait que Marilyn lui aurait
confié avoir eu une rencontre avec son
père biologique stanleyford suite
justement une hospitalisation la
découverte aujourd'hui de cette carte
vient vraiment accréditer cette théorie
donc ils ont dû se croiser ou en tout
cas échanger à un moment alors on va
préciser que cette carte n'est pas datée
nous elle n'est pas datée mais étant
dans cette carte en plus en fait on
estime quand on fait un peu de recherche
marine a fait quand même plusieurs
séjours en clinique ou à l'hôpital mais
c'est sans doute une carte qui date de
52 qui est l'époque où elle vit à Los
Angeles où elle accède vraiment à la
notoriété et où elle a une opération de
l'appendicite qui est très médiatisée
par les studios elle pose à l'hôpital
c'est auparavant et c'est sans doute là
où before a eu vent de cette
hospitalisation il y a c'est peut-être
manifesté ou à France pendant la
convalescence voilà et c'est la seule
correspondance qu'on connaisse de entre
le c'est la seule existence de Marilyn
Monroe oui ce qui est intéressant c'est
que par rapport au documentaire qui donc
base la souffrance de Marilyn sur le
fait de ne pas connaître son père en
fait non la souffrance de Marilyn si il
faut trouver une source et encore il
faut pas uniquement parler de Marilyn en
tant que femme qui souffre mais s'il
faut lui trouver une source c'est plutôt
le refus de son père de vraiment la
fréquenter c'est-à-dire on devine que il
y a eu de la part de Marilyn une quête
pour le retrouver pour renouer avec lui
et lui de façon on le sait avec une
autre famille etc donc c'était plutôt le
le déni de paternité qui était un
problème et pas vraiment l'identité de
son père et d'ailleurs on voit un détail
que la proximité était quand même pas
très grande parce que il se trompe dans
l'orthographe il écrit avec 2 y
absolument on va voir si vous voulez
bien un premier extrait du documentaire
il s'agit des premiers pas de Marilyn
Monroe devant une caméra c'est une
caméra de famille c'est un film de
famille
nous sommes en 1941 Normandie prend
conscience de son immense pouvoir de
séduction
c'est à cet instant qu'une petite caméra
la filme pour la première fois
[Musique]
avec quelques amis et membres de la
famille
1941 à la entre 15 et 16 ans plus vieux
que ça un peu plus vieux que ça
dites-vous quoi qu'il en soit ce on
découvre une femme brune qui va devenir
bronde blonde c'est Maryline avec
d'abord pin-up collectionnant les
couvertures de magazines débutant de
courant les officines de producteurs à
la fin des années 40 et au tout début
des années 50 à con la doit cette
métaphore on la doit elle-même elle
souhaitait devenir blonde elle
souhaitait devenir une une starlette
d'Hollywood on la doit pas on la doit
d'abord à une femme qui s'appelle
Émeline Snee qui dirige une agence de
mannequin qui est la Bluebook modèle
agency qui est l'agence en fait qui va
recruter Marilyn sur les conseils d'un
photographe et David konover qui qui
fait un reportage pour l'armée
américaine et qui va découvrir mareline
en allant dans une chaîne de production
de parachute et qui va découvrir cette
jeune fille bouclée rousse et il va
faire des photos il va lui dire mais en
fait arrête ça et tu es vraiment fait
pour ça et c'est lui qui va en parler à
un autre ami photographe qui va
recommander cette jeune fille à cette
agence de mannequin et elle va commencer
une nouvelle carrière en posant pour des
magazines pour des publicités et c'est
lors de ces mois où elle commence à
avoir une activité professionnelle de
mannequin qu'à un moment elle a
l'opportunité de faire une pub pour un
shampoing on lui dit il faut que tu sois
blonde et c'est là où elle va commencer
la métamorphose parce que c'est vraiment
ça Marilyn c'est la métamorphose
perpétuelle c'est-à-dire qu'elle se
réinvente non-stop est-ce que c'est une
femme malléable à l'époque Marilyn
Monroe et escala ses rêves de de star de
toute façon à Hollywood il faut être un
petit peu malléable et même beaucoup on
y reviendra sans doute et encore elle a
pas été l'une des plus malléables on
sait que on connaît des des des des
itinéraires comme John Crawford qui se à
qui on a forcé à se faire l'implantation
des cheveux plus hauts on vous parle là
d'opération chirurgicale de changer la
forme des paupières enfin Hollywood a
été beaucoup plus violent avec d'autres
actrices qu'avec Maryline Marilyn elle a
finalement pas été si en terme de corps
si violenté que ça si si une deux
opérations esthétiques ce qui est quand
même frappant je voudrais juste revenir
à cette photo enfin où à ce film de
famille c'est vrai qu'elle est déjà
d'une photo génie incroyable il y a
quelque chose qui se passe quand on la
voit mais on a tous dans nos beaux
petits rois des photos de nos mères de
nos grands-mères des époques de des
années 50 ou même des années 60 avec ce
genre de physique ce genre de beauté
pourra tout à fait honnête ma maman
quand elle était jeune ressemblait à
Sainte-Marie line là pas et c'est dingue
parce que il y a quelque chose encore de
normal d'extrêmement vintage et
délicieux mais normal et tout d'un coup
effectivement la blondeur et puis aussi
l'intelligence de cette femme parce que
on peut pas on peut pas devenir ce
qu'elle est devenue sans être d'une
finesse
créature
mythologie et contrairement à ce qu'on
entend souvent on dit les studios on
transformait c'est pas vrai en fait elle
a été l'artisan de sa transformation et
elle a eu ce goût très sûr de trouver
les bons artisans quelle est la
compagnie pour sa elle a le maquilleur
qui va bien la coiffeuse qui va bien et
c'est vraiment elle va se constituer une
garde rapprochée qui vont l'aider je
dirais à partir du moment où elle
commence à travailler comme starlette
jusqu'en gros en 52 où elle tourne
Niagara ou là tous ensemble ils trouvent
le visage le visage de ce que va être
Marilyn pour les années à venir 30 films
dans la dans le palmarès 29 et demi
elle est morte elle est morte pendant le
tournage du dernier on en garde combien
des films qui ont vraiment marqué le
cinéma de cette époque là parmi ces 30
films dans sa filmographie elle
il y a une bonne dizaine quand même une
bonne dizaine de qu'on pourrait
quasiment qualifier de chef-d'œuvre ou
pas loin
vous l'avez
cités
un peu
compliqué à comprendre aussi parce qu'on
sait très bien que Marine très vite va
tourner le dos Hollywood vouloir évoluer
dans sa carrière suivre les cours de la
tortudio monter sa société de production
et malgré tout quand on regarde ces
films elle joue toujours des chanteuses
des meneuses de revue des actrices des
danseuses elle joue quasiment jamais des
femmes dans la vie avec un vrai métier
et donc bien grâce à un peu une
exception mais non il y a les hommes
préfèrent les blondes il y a certains
même choc Les Désaxés
donc ce qui a pratiquement un film un
peu autopsie de Maryline en avance
écrit en plus par l'homme qui venait de
la quitter Arthur Miller qui était en
train la quitté sur le tournage c'est
vraiment un film où là alors oui elle
est une ancienne effeuilleuse enfin mais
on sait même pas quel est son métier
mais là pour le coup c'est une femme
normale une femme normale et qui se qui
se bat contre
l'agressivité masculine contre un monde
masculin qui veut exister coûte que
coûte au milieu des hommes donc là elle
on la voit un des rares
pas un seul Oscar non un Golden Globes
est-ce que la souffeur d'un manque de
reconnaissance de la profession
elle a eu la chance épauler pendant la
première partie de sa carrière par la
presse ça c'est elle a été très forte
c'était quand même un génie des
relations publiques elle savait très
très bien gérer son image mais la
reconnaissance de ses pairs n'est pas
vraiment venue et son grand drame c'est
quand elle arrive à donc monter sa
société de production renégocier son
contrat avec la avec la Fox elle revient
tourner arrêt d'autobus de Joshua Logan
où elle fait une composition assez
subtile et tout le monde dit c'est
formidable c'est son grand rôle l'allée
en 1956 en 56 elle va être nommée elle
va être nommée et elle n'est pas nommée
à l'Oscar donc ça c'était assez dur
ouais mais je pense que ce qu'il avait
souffrir c'est que vraiment
le système même d'Hollywood confondait
ses rôles
desserventés ou en tout cas de Candide
avec ce qu'elle était c'était alors que
cette femme était elle était passionnée
par la psychanalyse de Elysée énormément
elle était une femme d'affaires à sa
manière l'une des premières Hollywood a
essayé de faire sa carrière vraiment
indépendamment
ce qui est intéressant c'est que c'est
vraiment une femme de cinéma de cinéma
quand on consulte on a quand même la
chance d'avoir accès à beaucoup
d'archives aujourd'hui c'est scénario à
noter sur les tournages c'est énormément
de remarques très fines sur une répartie
qui ne marche pas ça il faut le filmer
comme si ça c'est faut resserrer le
public n'aimera pas et on se dit c'est
quand même terrible que le studio ne
l'est pas plus écouté
le monde de Hollywood ne se soit pas
rendu compte en fait de vraiment de de
la l'épaisseur en fait de son talent et
vous le disiez de l'un et l'autre
d'ailleurs elle a eu la volonté de
prendre ses distances vis-à-vis de des
studios et notamment de la Fox en créant
sa propre société de production elle se
justifiait de cette manière à l'époque
mon combat avec les studios n'est pas au
sujet de l'argent mais des droits
humains j'en ai marre d'être connu comme
celle qui a des formes je vais leur
montrer que je suis capable
et est-ce que on l'a toujours décrit
comme tel et on l'a décrit encore comme
tel aujourd'hui
ça c'est un qualificatif qu'elle
jugeait comment
il y a un bon mot qu'on lui rapporte et
qu'on a d'ailleurs c'est marrant parce
que la plupart des bons mots qu'on lui
rapporte son vrai on retrouve des traces
et c'était pas écrit par des gens du
service publicité elle avait vraiment
assumé d'être un sexe symbole elle a eu
cette déclaration un jour je lui ai dit
mais vous êtes un sexe symbole ça vous
gêne pas elle a dit mais vous savez moi
déjà symbole symbole je croyais que
c'était un instrument de musique donc
petite blague et ensuite il a dit mais
si je dois être le symbole de quelque
chose le sexe c'est pas si mal donc
c'est une ce qu'on appelle les
mondroïdes c'est remarques comme ça qui
ont l'air d'être assez amusantes et qui
sont en réalité plutôt frappés du bon
sens oui elle assumer ça elle avait bâti
ce personnage de femmes magnifiques
effectivement très sexuel mais en
réalité qui était aussi un peu compensée
par un côté enfantin elle était pas
menaçante
c'est à dire que d'abord elle avait
beaucoup de dérision aussi par rapport à
ça si elle s'était
détruite ainsi il y avait donc une
conscience de de la créature qu'elle
avait voulu devenir donc elle n'était
pas du tout juste sexe symbole
pratiquement par
comme une victime et après effectivement
il y avait une part d'enfance
d'innocence de candeur de c'est ce
mélange là toute façon c'est ce mélange
là parce que il y a des avagarres il y a
des la nature neuves il y a des
Elizabeth Taylor il y a des Elizabeth
Taylor je vais dire il y en a à
Hollywood elles font la queue
Marilyn c'est ça c'est cette part
d'enfance cette chose dans le regard
cette pureté qui fait que c'est aussi la
fille qu'on aimerait avoir c'est aussi
la Girls Next Door maintenant la
l'expression est et vulgarisée mais
c'est vrai c'est le principe même
d'ailleurs de cette André de flexion
dans cet ordre réflexion c'est la
voisine et la voisine toute mignonne
en nuisette alors elle est en nuisette
certes mais c'est parce qu'il fait très
très chaud et qu'elle a mis son pull
angora au pour le rafraîchir mais un
type voit débarquer cette voisine là
mais elle elle fait absolument rien pour
le séduire elle est juste elle mais bon
ça suffit amplement il faut dire mais
c'est ça c'est cette ambiguïté constante
qui fait la magie qui fait le mystère
total absolu et éternel cet an de
réflexion 1957 c'est avec cette fameuse
scène 44 pardon 54 avec cette fameuse
scène à cette robe soulevée par la
grille d'aération du métro ça c'est une
image
c'est d'abord un coup de pub génial
parce que en réalité Wilder tourne
l'extérieur à New York en sachant très
bien qu'il va pas utiliser la séquence
puisque la presse est au courant il y a
une full monstrueuse ça dure jusqu'à 1h
du matin ils font j'ai pas combien de
prises mais les gens hurlent dès qu'il y
a le le ventilo qui est mis en marche
etc et regardez rien de ce qui a été
filmé sur la ne sera utilisé dans le
film ils vont tout recréer en studio au
cap de manière professionnelle quelques
semaines par la suite mais oui ça a été
c'est devenu une image et une image qui
n'existe pas dans le film puisque vous
ne pouvez pas à l'époque filmer une
femme dont la jupe se soulève c'est
impossible avec le code Hollywood donc
en fait vous avez le plan de la grille
de métro les jambes le plan sur le
visage mais entre les deux ça n'existe
pas
Madison se fait regarder le 29 mai
1962 il s'agissait de célébrer les 45
ans de John Fitzgerald Kennedy quel a
été la teneur réellement de cette
supposée relation entre Marilyn Monroe
et les Kennedy a commencé par John
Fitzgerald Kennedy déjà moi je voudrais
revenir sur ces images qu'on les voit
tourner en boucle et c'est vrai qu'elle
a ce côté éthéré incroyable il y a on
raconte souvent mais oui elle était ivre
la petite sur scène ont souvent on voit
des images aussi un peu d'amorce ou
Peter lawherford qui le maître de
cérémonie et qui est le beau-frère de
Kennedy qui l'annonce et il y a
roulement tambour elle est pas là
en réalité tout est écrit Marie il y a
des photos qui existent où on voit les
répétitions et il y a un jeu de mot il y
a des programmes qui sont imprimés il a
toujours été prévu qu'elle arrive comme
ça au milieu et non pas enfin comme on
le dit souvent avec des fausses arrivées
et c'est un c'est une blague sur ces
retards que tout le monde connaît
d'ailleurs le présentateur la présentera
comme the light
un peu terrible en retard
elle n'est ni sous le ni à soumet par
les médicaments
c'est un numéro c'est un numéro et c'est
elle qui a
conçu la robe qui voulait quelque chose
d'exceptionnel ce soir là enfin elle a
vraiment organisé mis en scène cette
apparition alors ça ne répond pas à ma
question
réelles entre John Fitzgerald Kennedy
Marilyn Monroe Bob Kennedy son frère et
Marilyn Monroe mais est-ce que je peux
juste rajouter que c'est intéressant
j'aurais ma réponse
les médias ou l'histoire veut retenir
constamment donc que Marilyn est fragile
que Marilyn titube que Marilyn ça ne va
pas que que Marilyn est une pauvre
créature comme ça
qui murmure mais non marilyn est une
actrice qui prépare son entrée en scène
avec de l'autodérision et on retient
tout le contraire et elle a même
dissimulé qu'elle avait qu'elle aurait
ce genre de tenue parce que à un moment
le producteur des choses dit oui c'est
quand même voilà faut faire attention
non vous inquiétez pas alors comment ça
robe voilà alors oui alors les relations
les relations avec moi j'étais pas là
on parle du numéro un des États-Unis
vraisemblablement c'est pas sûr
si en fait on a alors dans le on
continue on les interprétations qui ont
été faites de ce de cet extrait qu'on
vient de voir certains y ont vu une
déclaration d'amour aussi c'est
compliqué parce qu'on parle de choses
qui sont passées à 60 ans les gens sont
décédés depuis on a vécu aussi plusieurs
époques dans les années 90 on a eu toute
une littérature complotiste nous
expliquant que elle s'était tapé les
deux frères que elle était il y avait
des micro partout que la CIA faisait
chanter le qui faisait chanter ouvert
c'est et puis après il y a maintenant
on a une je dirais des révisionnistes
qui me disent mais pas du tout oui c'est
bien passé ils se sont jamais croisés il
y a jamais rien eu moi je pense que la
vérité elle est entre les deux j'ai eu
la chance de rencontrer vous le disiez
au début de l'émission quelques
photographes qu'on travaille avec elle
donc ce qu'on travaille avec elle dans
les derniers mois de sa vie dont
bershtern et qui m'a dit il y a quelques
années bien sûr ils étaient ensemble
tout le monde le savait juste à l'époque
on en parlait pas donc là vous parlez de
John fieldger
professionnelles d'être en contact avec
Robert Kennedy puisque à l'époque
Kennedy travaillait avec la Fox sur
l'adaptation d'un livre de John Kennedy
et marilynam avait des difficultés avec
la Fox donc à un moment il y a des
traces aussi d'appel etc sans doute pour
des raisons professionnelles est-ce
qu'il y a pas un syndrome Mika et en moi
à ce moment-là ça vite sa carrière
moi je crois pas du tout à ça non parce
que enfin elle est la plus grande
créature de cinéma et de de
show-business et de et de fiction
américaine à ce moment là il est le plus
grand homme politique et de fiction
américaine il y a rien d'étonnant à ce
que tout d'un coup on se brûle les ailes
ensemble enfin je veux dire c'est normal
enfin
on est plus étonné aujourd'hui que dans
des cocktails une star en croise une
autre et finissant en couple avec des
couples même souvent absurdes de nos
jours donc là il y a vraiment ces mêmes
une évidence c'est la plus belle femme
du monde c'est le le chef du monde
civilisé bon voilà après évidemment que
il y a un en fait c'est pas du tout
qu'elle se brûle les ailes c'est que
l'exigence
je pense c'est que c'est l'exigence en
fait et presque l'utopie l'idéalisme qui
va finir par la ronger la rendre malade
que le dernier tournage où elle ne
s'entend pas avec George cucor c'est
parce que elle veut jouer d'une certaine
manière que cul corps la traite mal que
il lui pour lui allait la Maryline de
d'habitude allez hop hop hop hop tu te
mets tu te mets en maillot de bain dans
une piscine et puis on enchaîne
elle elle fait un virage en 180 degrés
elle elle a acheté une maison à Los
Angeles c'est la première fois qu'elle
âge qu'elle achète une maison et entendu
et découvert dans ce film elle elle va
elle elle se fait un cercle d'amis elle
donne une interview parce que comme elle
s'est fait renvoyer du du tournage de
Samsung elle se bat avec ses armes qui
sont l'opinion publique et la presse et
elle donne des interviews dont une dans
Live magazine qui paraît quelques jours
elle paraît le choix le 3 août avant
vraiment ça disparition
assez profonde et quand on la relie on
est vraiment frappé par le l'esprit
l'intelligence la vivacité la profondeur
de ses propos et donc pour moi non c'est
pas quelqu'un voilà c'est pas une
créature fragile brisée par un système
pas du tout la manière dont on l'a
décrit tout de même à l'entrée de ces
années 60 c'est une femme aussi très
dépendante des amphétamines des
barbituriques de l'alcool une femme
dépressive
victime donc c'était faible estime de
soi voilà ce qu'on peut lire aussi sur
Marilyn Monroe à l'entrée de ces années
60 et elle mourra vous l'avez dit bien
entendu le 4 mousse le 4 août 1962 ça
aussi c'est la vraie Maryline tel qu'on
l'a décrit et tout ce que vous avez dit
est vrai tout ce que vous avez dit est
faux d'accord on a on a autant de
témoins qui vous disent c'était vraiment
une loque c'était pas possible elle est
arrivée deux jours en retard sur le
tournage on y arrive pas que des gens
qui l'ont vu au même moment et qui
disent qui témoignent des gens que j'ai
rencontré qui dit c'était extraordinaire
elle m'a présenté ses projets j'ai visé
la maison elle voulait monter une
nouvelle maison de production avec
Brando c'était formidable elle avait
plein d'énergie c'était magnifique de
l'avoir comme ça c'est Marilyn il y a un
mot qui la résume c'est paradoxe elle
est tout et son contraire tout le temps
c'est pour ça c'est aussi compliqué de
la saisir mais c'est sans doute pour ça
que 60 ans après elle est toujours là
s'il y a peut-être un mot plus médical
parce que dépressive si un mot plus
médical c'est peut-être
maniaco-dépressive mais en tout cas il y
a quelque chose vous parlez de paradoxe
c'est presque de la bipolarité mais
somptueuse c'est à dire qu'effectivement
je pense qu'il y a des moments il y a
des vraiment des moments de force absolu
de projet
de d'ancrage de on achète une maison
recommence une vie et puis des moments
parce que là on est parce qu'elle est
confrontée pour le coup c'est pas une
question d'être broyé mais elle est
confrontée
elle a fait des choix de mecs qui se
sont pas avérés d'une grande même quand
elle choisit
sur Miller qui est un intellectuel
finalement il finit par la quitter pour
enfin un truc de dingue donc
effectivement c'est vraiment force et
fragilité non mais force et difficulté à
tenir non mais surtout il faut pas
oublier aussi à l'époque de ce que c'est
pour une actrice de ce niveau là elle
fait 30 films en 16 ans il faut avoir
une idée elle monte une boîte de
production elle fait des photos non-stop
il y a des milliers de séances enfin
elle n'a jamais arrêté de travailler et
pour avoir ce niveau d'énergie comment
ça fonctionne et ben on le sait il y a
des amphétamines vous avez le docteur
des studios qui vient vous voir qui vous
fait une piqûre le matin quand on tourne
un film Hollywood on est réveillé à 4h
du matin la limousine vient vous
chercher à 5h et vous emmène au sujet
pour être maquillée pendant deux heures
parce que c'est ça aussi le ça prend de
créer ce personnage qu'on va filmer et
le soir on rentre chez soi on a les les
lignes à apprendre pour le lendemain
donc ça abîme dernière extrait du
documentaire nous sommes le 4 août 1962
c'est le jour de la mort de Marilyn
Monroe
le soir du 4 août 1962 Marilyn s'est
ennu sur son lit dans sa maison d'Elena
Drive à Los Angeles
elle a vu son psychiatre à plusieurs
reprises dans la journée le docteur
Ralph Greenson leurs échanges long
bouleversé
elle appelle des proches au téléphone
ses propos sont flous
puis à 22h environ
Normandin et Marilyn Monroe s'éteignent
en portant leurs secrets et leurs démons
[Musique]
alors là encore il y a une énigme de
quoi est morte Marilyn Monroe
visiblement la thèse vers laquelle on
tend le plus aujourd'hui c'est tout
simplement un accident médical
[Musique]
c'est là aussi c'est ça remonte à
tellement longtemps que ça devient
compliqué de savoir moi j'ai une théorie
qui est morte de l'incompétence de son
entourage elle était quand même cernée
par une armée de bras cassés
mais c'est très très difficile de savoir
aujourd'hui oui je suis assez d'accord
il y a il y a des trous dans l'emploi
dans l'emploi du temps enfin à partir du
moment enfin les coups de fil pour
appeler à l'aide de l'entourage et tout
ça tout ça est assez flou c'est
d'ailleurs dans ce flou que la parano et
le complotisme c'est complètement inséré
avec oui mais c'était le temps qu'ils
appellent la CIA c'était le temps que il
nettoie la scène du crime c'était le
temps mais non pas du tout je pense que
c'était c'est parce que oui ça doit être
enfin moi mon avis c'est une erreur
médicamenteuse on lui-même qu'elle
aurait eu des relations avec des
communistes cubains c'est pour ça que le
radiateur
Roswell et qu'elle serait peut-être
faire une conférence de presse on
rajoute un peu de mafia là dessus aussi
parce qu'elle avait des potes à Las
Vegas et allons-y quoi donc bon donc
autrement dit on ne connaît pas encore
le non non et on connaît pas enfin si on
connaît le fin mot de Romy Schneider
mais on sait aussi toujours demander si
c'était un accident ou plus que ça voilà
en fait c'est c'est juste en fait ce qui
est fou c'est que c'est l'histoire d'un
d'une femme qui qui meurt peut-être
presque trop simplement pour ce qu'elle
était pour ce qu'elle représentait donc
il faut absolument créer de la fiction
encore sur sa mort alors que c'est juste
une femme sans doute qui s'est éteinte
au sens vraiment presque littéral du
terme un peu de calmant trop et elle
s'est éteinte voilà mais le fait qu'elle
disparaisse comme ça qu'elle s'éteigne
ça c'est pas possible en fait c'est pas
possible donc il faut inventer autour
bon alors certains inventent y compris
dans le milieu du cinéma c'est le cas de
Audrey Dominique qui a réalisé blonde
qui est un film disponible sur Netflix
qui a été présenté à la Mostra de Venise
durant cette année 2022 qui a eu un
véritable succès mais qui présente
Marilyn Monroe sur un personnage sous un
angle très particulier très dépressive
et finalement tout ce que vous avez mis
de côté dans cette émission très
doloriste très doloriste
totale puisque c'est adaptée du livre de
Just Carlos du même nom qui était un
roman pour le coup qui a vraiment été
planté comme comme tel là le film
Dominique est présenté comme un faux
biopix qui est une drôle de
d'appellation
moi j'ai eu la chance de le découvrir
lors de sa présentation officielle à
Venise et c'est vrai que j'ai pour la
première fois était bluffé par une
actrice qui a réussi dans certains plans
à me faire croire qu'elle était Marilyn
Monroe donc aladdarma c'est absolument
formidable il y a un travail de
institution de soins apportés à la
production du film phénoménal parce que
la plupart des scènes sont arrêtés des
photos qui ont été qui prennent vie
comme ça donc c'est assez fascinant mais
tout le reste c'est vrai que c'est un
peu triste essayer de détruire l'image
de Marilyn Monroe ou l'image qu'on garde
nationalité
il y a des complaisances dans la mise en
scène il y a vraiment une recherche
aussi de temps de la de la chair un peu
de la chair en souffrance donc ce plan
sur la sur un sur une fausse couche sur
un avortement sur des choses comme ça
enfin qui font de qui font de cette
femme une fois de plus uniquement un
corps et moi ça c'est ça qui me gêne et
encore qui chouigne ou qui pleure ou qui
tombe voilà
un corps qui saigne un corps mais mince
donc une fois de plus même dans ce qui
est censé être un hommage on oublie le
haut là l'esprit une scène où on la voit
travailler être la grande actrice
qu'elle a été c'est hallucinant bon
lutter le spectateurs jugeront en tout
cas ils peuvent aller voir ce film
blonde pour se faire même une idée c'est
le dernier film en tout cas consacra
Marilyn Monroe qui soit sorti à ce jour
Marilyn Monroe a 10 ans en 2012 généré
27 millions de dollars par an à son
image ça reste une icône inégalée
aujourd'hui Marilyn Monroe de ce point
de vue là je crois que Elvis aussi
rapporte beaucoup d'argent quoi mais
elle fait partie dans le classement de
Forbes chaque année elle est quand même
dans le top 10 de celle qui génère
beaucoup de revenus mais il faut savoir
que c'est devenu aussi une industrie un
business puisque à sa mort une partie
une grande partie de ses effets
personnel elle les a léguées par
testament à son professeur d'art
dramatique lis Strasberg avait quand
même une petite phrase dans le testament
qui était gelègue à mon professeur mais
bien et ses personnel charge à lui de
les distribuer à mes collègues et amis
mais il a oublié la fin de la phrase il
a tout gardé il est décédé en 82 et ça
veuve à ce moment-là à créer elle elle a
pas oublié non plus de s'intéresser au
sujet elle a créé la marque Marilyn
qu'elle a déposé et elle vit très bien
depuis toutes ces années en créant des
licences c'est comme ça que vous avez
des objets dérivés des droits etc le
pouf Maryline le mug Maryline c'est
parmi les courriers retrouvés
chez lui qu'on a retrouvé
la documentation il faut savoir que tout
ce qui a touché Maryline aujourd'hui
vaut de l'or une un mémo sur lequel elle
a écrit à la gouvernante remède de
bouteilles de lait ça vaut 400 dollars
aux enchères le mot que je vous ai
montré tout à l'heure là il est estimé à
3000 dollars je pense qu'il va partir à
30 000 et votre propre collection est
toujours visible en tout cas une partie
d'entre elles la galerie Lumière de Lyon
peuvent s'y rendre ça sera jusqu'à la
fin du mois de décembre l'année évalué
cette collection des objets de Marilyn
que que vous détenez vous-même moi j'ai
pas d'objet je collectionne uniquement
des photos des photos et j'ai arrêté de
compter combien j'en avais il y a
quelques temps parce que j'en ai trop
mais si je peux me permettre pour finir
c'est vrai qu'il y a bon ben on peut
s'asseoir sur des poufs Maryline acheter
des gommes Marilyn ou à boire dans des
mugs Marylin certes et que c'est vrai
que c'est devenu une image pop voilà
c'est de la pop culture au cube merci
warole aussi mais franchement pour même
pour la jeune génération il faut que les
gens tout bêtement revoir ses films ou
certaines de ces interviews comme ça en
noir et blanc et là il comprendront il
comprendront que c'est pas c'est pas
enfin c'est pas innocent c'est pas un
hasard si cette femme est devenue
mythique c'est très vrai c'est même vrai
dans les mauvais films parce que on a
fait quelques-uns aussi et même dans les
mauvais films elle est formidable et ça
c'est vraiment la marque des grandes
actrices et on rappellera on l'a déjà
dit que ça filmographie compte 29
films et demi mais on va dire 30 et vous
en avez retenu l'un et l'autre comme
étant marquant pour cette période du
cinéma américain une dizaine une bonne
dizaine merci vraiment à tous les deux
merci d'avoir parlé de Marilyn Monroe
sur ce plateau après ce film que nous
avons pu voir ensemble vos réactions ça
sera sur hashtag des Badoc sur Twitter
bien entendu merci c'est le massali qui
comme à la coutumée m'a aidé à préparer
cette émission puis je vous donne
rendez-vous pour un prochain débat doc
et ça sera bien entendu avec son
documentaire et son débat à bientôt
[Musique]